new here at 11 o'clock two men save a
life at a local soccer game what started
as a normal day in march took a turn for
one woman who had a heart attack
watching her granddaughters play now
luckily though law enforcement officers
were there to step in and today they
were honored for their efforts sasha
loftus joining us tonight with the
details denise and brian these two men
were at the right place at exactly the
right time today as they reunited with
the woman they saved she said she will
never forget the second chance they've
given her
i didn't believe it
what started as a normal day at her
granddaughter's spring soccer game
suddenly turned terrifying for gene
dahlberg when my son turned around and
screamed help gene had a heart attack
and wasn't breathing that's when these
two jumped into action i hear screaming
i turned back and i see gene slumped
over in the chair metro police officer
brandon alvarado who was coaching the
game and his brother-in-law nevada state
trooper charles abernathy tapped into
their training we laid her down
started chest compressions with the help
of an icu nurse who was also in the
right place at the right time they were
able to keep gene alive and get her to
the hospital receiving the red cross
life saving award and three months later
she was here
to see abernathy and alvarado each
receive a red cross life-saving award
now as she moves forward
jean says she will never forget what
these two men gave her there's no words
to explain how grateful i am and they
know their decision to step in made all
the difference in the world there's just
a happiness that kind of overwhelms you
when you you see that you did something
to help somebody else have more days on
this earth
jean says because these chest
compressions were done so quickly she
didn't lose much oxygen to her brain and
has really recovered well and these
officers they encourage everyone to get
cpr
certified which is possible to help save
a life in this similar situation you
know we've talked about this before
we've gone through the certification but
it's been so many years you wonder if
you remember in an incident like that
yeah i think you have to redo it every
couple years they have a lot of classes
in las vegas and people want to check
them out we have them on our website
yeah i did one as well years ago and i
don't think i'd remember it you need the
refresher course a couple hours yeah
exactly saturday afternoon knock it out
for sure thanks